well you know ego is a big issue because
people like to be connected with what
they created money obviously making
money and having power is a very
important thing tied to ego and
certainly gets in the way of sharing and
people being willing to you know release
their ideas I think that you for me it's
very possible to create a safe place for
young people with good ideas it's a
matter of trust it's a matter of people
trusting each other and having you know
having no fear that they're going to be
taken advantage of or be hurt from
either an ego standpoint or a financial
standpoint the method of doing that I
think you have to do it by raising the
level of consciousness of the of people
particularly in scientific world to a
point where they really believe that in
order we have to improve our culture we
have to get unstuck from where we are I
don't have much trouble to communicating
with scientists on that level to me is
very similar to communicating with
juries personally I don't have a lot of
trouble with it I've I think I've been
able to make a few young engineers feel
very safe to disclose their information
to be entrust me with it what I'm trying
to develop is a system of what you call
mature scientists in expansive thinkers
that can do that with that can make a
safe place for people to share ideas and
that's the work in progress that's where
we're evolving
meet more new ones I think that on in
the last month or so I've met some that
I some whose names I could give freely
like Peter Diamandis I think it is great
along these lines it was he was a great
fine for me I think that some people in
terms of helping to expand the level of
consciousness people like Andrew Cohen
from enlightenment next I think that
kind of teaching will help tremendously
to expand people so that they will you
know work for the good of their culture
is compared to the egocentric kind of
inventors that we have really had
historically so every day I meeting more
people that I think that will make this
inner circle work and and I've met
several people whose names I wouldn't
feel real freely to give right now
because I don't think they would feel
safe but I think they will very sharp